it's like Derek Jackson know what
they're doing
absolutely yeah
absolutely they're they're Jackson is
hitting a target audience and the
majority of them are black women and he
knows that if I can get them I have them
hooked and it's sad to say but they're
going to
keep going because I'm not sure if this
stat is correct but I think that the
highest like unmarried demographic is
one of the highest I'll say one of the
highest is black woman and he knows that
if I
what he's saying is it feeding into
everything that is
them essentially
and it's it's hard to say because I am a
black woman and I I remember when I
first saw him and I was like oh yeah
like what he's saying is true like that
makes perfect sense and I really started
listening to him and I was and then all
that stuff happened like I said earlier
and I was like wait let me actually
listen and I had friends who we would
talk about things that he said and sit
down and be like oh did you see his
video today and just discuss it and it's
very
is very disheartening when people hear
something but don't actually like listen
and like think about it but they just
take it and they run with it well and I
think a lot of stuff like simply guys
kind of say it sounds nice and it works
well in theory like raise your standards
but it only works well like if you have
anything to offer a guy
and most modern women don't like how
many modern women have cookbooks how
many modern women are virgins
beans on toast not the fruit beans
which is like it doesn't mean you're a
bad person or anything but it's just
like
um you know it's like you're you're
asking for BMW prices when you're a used
Honda Civic how many buyers you gonna
get
and if you do get a buyer you know damn
well you scam the man and all these
girls and and then them particular girls
you're talking about if you ask them
would you rate yourself out of 10 I'm a
10.
like so some will say 12 actually don't
forget it's mad I break the scale that's
what they say well would you bring or
the worst one you're asking what do you
bring to the table table like
what's his name Derek if he rated people
like his fans oh that would be good that
would be really good he's gonna say yeah
yeah guys are tense yeah yeah
you literally have to I I oh my God I
would kill to get that man on the show
after this no I think it'd be funny like
I don't know I feel like you can make
some funny content ah it'd be good
I would ask him I'd be like why are you
something like what are you doing here
oh I don't think he'd come on I don't
know I just have a feeling the heat will
be too much
um do the next clip blessing
is there anyone you can think of who's a
bigger scent than Derek Jackson this
next person or the one we're about to
watch later oh you think he's bigger no
I don't
I mean
I'm sorry I did trust me once you see it
you cannot see it I'm about to ruin so
many dating games
losing and that applies here secondly I
get it it's like well she's taking
everything I invested into him no she
ain't she about to take everything he
was using to stress you out while
blaming it on you she just don't know it
yet and it seems like he's able to give
her you know all of these different
fruits of of your labor you know all of
this good treatment this money whatever
he was only able to do that because he
was giving you the rest of him he was
giving her the best while giving you the
rest now that she's in your spot he
about to give her the rest he's about to
give her all of that depression he was
projecting onto you because he don't
need no therapist that's what she about
to get that's all she's taken from you
she's taking his criticism whenever his
money get low she's about to take on all
of that neglect those excuses how little
that he was willing to help you around
the house and but whenever he took out
the trash once a week he wanted to be
treated like a cane That's what she
about to get she again she just don't
know it yet everything that he was
blaming on you she about to realize you
were not the problem and on top of that
she's no longer the new toy and he still
needs that spot filled now that she's
taking on yours he still needs that spot
filled because we're not talking about a
guy that made his mistakes he did his
wrong but you know he wants to make it
right he's repenting no we're talking
about a guy that stepped out moved out
and he don't see nothing wrong with it
man what that girl took from you was a
blessing to you you need to be thanking
her and somebody need to be praying for
her because she next
oh
I have a feeling that he is he talking
to anybody is this like from like a show
or anything I don't know Michael you
gotta I don't know what he's saying I
don't know he always like sitting in his
room acting like he's talking to
somebody but he's not talking anymore
but it's not the corner of the room yeah
it's the it again I was like is this you
are you just exposing Yourself by saying
all this stuff it I want to know what
what people he knows because I've
it's just like mind-blowing at the stuff
he's saying because it doesn't it
doesn't seem realistic the things that
he's saying I'm like the people that you
know really act like this and are really
doing these things or are or was this
just your story and you're just
portraying as it's somebody that you
know now imagine being his wife like
hearing him
you know it just sounds like she's like
you don't help her on the house that was
you you took the trash out once and you
wanted to be treated like a king the
rest of you you were streaming
depression on me it was you I by his own
logic his wife should have left him by
his own logic she did yeah but I mean
indefinitely Yeah by his logic divorced
like so he's just saying anything again
you know do as I say not as I do
crap I think he's just playing he just
knows what sells he knows he can just
drum up the audience he can get his
subscribers it's very common it's really
Shadow he's doing what he's preaching
himself so and he says a lot in in the
video it's not it's not really a quick
video he's saying a lot of things so all
it is is women feel good women feel good
it's not your fault it's the man's fault
yeah bro like it's it's a it's a trick
has he ever done a video like opposite
where he's like trying to balance out
you know the field and I don't know
all the [ __ ] I've seen is
Sam I have not seen it's really like
offensive to men like even the therapy
and all that stuff like that's a
sensitive topic that's why no one don't
like you yeah
you never hear those guys say yes Derek
come on his wife's in the background
probably saying I told you to get
therapy you narcissist
yo she should come out with her own
channel
Jackson's wife tells off she
she's give dating advice and not say his
name
how to spot a narcissist yeah come on I
knew somebody that went through this aka
me
if you're ever in this situation I mean
he made money off of her yeah
I do have a question for the ladies uh
Derek said something in his uh first
video about
the realistic
uh qualities that a man wants for a
woman and he was talking about oh we
want our
um or unrealistic sorry we want our
woman to cook clean and then
um have sex with us and then cook us
dinner if a man was a pain everything
for you and all he asked for you was to
cook clean make sure everything's
straightened at the house take care of
the kids and then pleasure him would you
think that's an unrealistic ask of him
to do no no no I don't think so either
that's a very healthy man-woman
relationship that's it what if he wasn't
paying all the bills do you still think
that that's okay
um
if it's like
so um obviously we're doing like half
and half bills or whatever yeah 50 50. I
feel like
hmm
with that I think
there should be more roles for the both
of us then like more equal roles
um if we're both making that if we're
both paying bills or it's like even even
50 50 whatever
um I think you should both be
taking on more roles I would try to
balance it more I guess you could say so
I would say it it depends on
the type of the type of like one who's
ever home more but the type of job that
the woman may have because I feel like
nowadays
a lot of people can work from home but I
see that more men still go into work so
if the wife is working from home she can
do it the job and still do XYZ and then
still be ready for her man when she come
home
foreign
don't you think that men do things like
fixing stuff around the house
and like they're expected to like fix
things mow the lawn yeah so then even if
it's 50 50 shouldn't we still be
expected to do those things
oh yeah I think so I would but I don't
want you to be looking I don't want to
be exhausted it has to kind of balance
like if I'm meeting you a bit halfway I
still I'm still because I'm a woman and
that's just in me anyway like I'm not
gonna stop being a homemaker do you
understand what I mean but obviously I'm
not I don't want to be doing all of it
and I'm completely tired and there you
can help me do you understand because
then I'm gonna feel like I'm being taken
advantage of do you think men would say
the same thing for like you know fixing
stuff around the house mowing the lawn
yard work
[Laughter]
um because if he's like mowing the lawn
and doing work around the house right so
then she would be doing laundry washing
dishes and doing you know whatever else
there's still that balance there unless
really I feel like actually to move the
Lord and do that job
I feel like our jobs are easier nowadays
but yeah I mean we got [ __ ] automated
dishwasher dishwasher laundry machine
nice cool call I would I would rather do
that I hate mowing the lawn actually
I've never mowed the
lawnfish
for cars they would like they would do
the boy stuff can I see one finger yeah
something that's very awesome as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible